i have been burdened with glorious
purpose to review the latest thing to
come out from the mcu on disney plus
[Music]
i'm not actually burdened like no one's
making me do this i'm doing this because
i want to and i'm dropping this here
because this feels like a bigger deal
and you know i had debated whether or
not to do
things like the wand division or the
falcon winter soldier reviews here on
the main channel or over in the break
room where i actually ended up doing it
a break room of geeks subscribe if
you're not but uh we're gonna at least
do the premiere
here i may or may not continue to do
episode by episode reviews here
depending on what the view numbers are
frankly but i'll keep doing them
regardless they may just move to the
break room we'll see
again subscribe there if you haven't
loki
first episode glorious purpose
it's kind of hard to judge the show too
much based off this episode because this
is very much a
setup episode premieres tend to be one
of two things
most often what they are is
um something that will spend maybe the
first quarter of their run time
establishing everything that needs to
establish and then
try and be an expression of what a
standard episode of a show is meant to
be
like the other option which is what loki
is is something that is just
devoting the entire runtime of the
premiere episode to the setup now
honestly that's kind of what all the mcu
shows have been so far because none of
these
are at present designed with the intent
that they continue on for multiple
seasons
they might uh well maybe not one
division but falcon and winter soldier
conceivably could depending on how this
ends this probably could but they're not
being designed with the standard network
mentality of
we want this to last for as many seasons
as possible so we have a set formula for
what an episode is
that's not what this is doing so it
makes sense to devote pretty much the
entire first episode to
establishing what needs to be known
and it does a pretty good job of that
especially because it can be hard to do
what is basically an
exposition dump episode and also have it
be entertaining
that's not an easy thing to do and this
does it well
largely buoyed by the charm
of the actors involved tom hiddleston
obviously right up there
he actually does some really really good
emotional work in this i'm going to come
back to that
but also owen wilson with his laid-back
owen wilsonness the dynamic between him
and loki
is wonderful the two of them are just
so not similar at all which makes for
really good chemistry because they just
bring such different vibes to the table
watching them bounce off each other is
just delightful
i think largely i'm going to end up
talking about some of the logistics of
what we've learned in this because
like i said plot wise there isn't really
anything going on here that you couldn't
have gathered from the early trailers
this is the loki that escaped during the
events of avengers end game with the
tesseract
he has now been apprehended by the time
variants agency
uh who takes it upon themselves to
maintain the one
sacred timeline as they call it um that
is suppose what is supposed to happen
and loki is now a variant and is
deviating from that
however instead of simply resetting him
and making time the way it is
they are going to recruit him to try and
deal with a bigger problem that they've
got going on
elsewhere in time that's what happens
that's pretty much what anyone could
have guessed was going to be the premise
and this
really is nothing but premise setting so
let's talk about some of the details of
some of these
premises i am so far
pretty good with the time variance
agency first of all i like that it is
incredibly bureaucratic
i always love just in general the idea
of these
massive powerful almost god-like
entities in terms of what they're able
to do
and their capabilities and their sight
in it you know they see all they know
they can do all in like
it's just an office it's just a
bureaucratically run office
i just love that as a premise i that's
not something i really will ever
tire of it's one of the things i love
about beetlejuice where the afterlife is
this
messy bureaucracy or something like the
adjustment bureau which was a movie that
i really liked for
some of those same elements so i like
that in general
so i'm here for that some of the things
that they let well first of all
can we just call right now the time
keepers or whatever
they're going to turn out to be either
corrupt
or dead or a lie
that never existed in the first place
like it's
it is incredibly conspicuous that a we
don't meet any of them
b that they seem to basically have taken
it upon themselves to decide
what is or what isn't the thing that is
supposed to happen
and they answer to nobody so like
there's no way that's not gonna get
called out
like these sorts of things that always
happens ultimately
it happened eventually with the time
lords and doctor who
it happened with the time agency in um
legends of tomorrow and you know it's
always what
happens so i don't even think it's a
spoiler to claim that that's going to be
where things go
i am going to talk about this episode
pretty freely so i guess swirl the
warning i should have given
earlier except that like i said it's
pretty much all set up except for the
thing that happens at the very very very
very very end which i will save
to the end of the review okay so
moving on from that i do
like some of the things that this
manages to pretty seamlessly
let us know about how things are
operating within the mcu
first off it is established that there
is not
at present a multiverse
there used to be a multiverse but the
multiverse its very
existence caused tension and war and
problems
so we're seeding two ideas here that can
and probably will be picked up later
one multiverses are inherently dangerous
and two there is not one right now or at
least there is not supposed to be one
they even kind of drop and things that
feel like
they're setting up at least towards an
indication of what multiverse of madness
with doctor strange is gonna be about
less about
um i think what some of us probably
thought it was discovering the scope of
the multiverse and more about realizing
oh this is just bad if this
if this thing exists or is reintroduced
or if we accidentally created it
somewhere along the line or what have
you
the other thing that i kind of like
because i i had my own
um head canon for this but they kind of
confirmed it more or less
which is that i like that
the time the accepted timeline
includes time travel so
what i mean by that is you know when
loki got taken out because he was a
variant who was
messing with the established timeline i
did immediately think well the avengers
were messing with time as well now
before the show even addressed i thought
well like
yes but then they also like made a point
of going back and reset
and like trying to get things back to
the way they were so that they made as
little ripples as possible maybe that's
why they got away with it and i honestly
would have been fine just thinking that
without an explanation but instead they
actually say no
that's what they were supposed to do so
i kind of like that
the accepted version of time includes
messing with time like that that's
that's a nice little inceptiony kind of
layered thing like i just
that that's nice i dig that
i'm slightly iffy um
this is largely going to come down to
whether or not they
talk about it further and how they talk
about it
so right now the way the idea of there's
a way that time is supposed to go
is being framed largely like
the timekeepers have decided
this is what should happen which makes
it seem like
fate i'm not big on fate
as a i mean as a general philosophical
concept
nor as a narrative tool because
it's kind of lazy i mean like i said
the easy way to undercut that is to
determine that these people had no
business determining people's fates
anyways but that would be something for
down the road but just the idea
that like ultimately there is no free
will and if you
do stuff you're not supposed to you're
going to be forcibly put back to what
somebody else has decided is what you're
supposed to do
there are ways around introducing that
as a notion and still having it work at
least for me
one of them is um taking something like
this the way doctor who tends to look at
is like look
it's not that you have no free will it's
that everything has already happened
and the doctor can just travel along the
full scope of it
so it's not that you are not you don't
have the freedom to choose it's that you
have already chosen
but if something forces you to do
something other than what you yourself
would have chosen
or if in retaliation you forcibly break
what it was you yourself were choosing
to do that was part of the established
set timeline that's where things get
messy
now that's a little bit heady it's a
little bit metaphysical
and it might be more than the this show
is
willing to do and like i said there are
ways to sort of adjust it moving forward
depending on what happens ultimately to
the tva or the timekeepers or whatever
by the end of the
season like all this stuff might be
shaken up
but it does basically it does basically
present a world in which
everything we've seen up to this point
was predetermined by
these beings that we don't know i
love that as an implication but we'll
see where they go with it
if they go anywhere with it if they just
kind of leave it as is i'm a little bit
like
however talking about established and uh
timed them what was supposed to happen i
mentioned tom hiddleston
did some really good acting and he does
i mean first of all
he is wonderfully exasperated and he can
be charming he's got a great sort of
glare when he's ticked off but honestly
watching him see the reel
of the events of what was supposed to
happen to him
his mother dying odin
dying reuniting with
thor fighting for the people of asgard
and then his own death
watching him watch that
that was really really good stuff
he sold so much with
smiles and little breaths and tears
i felt like i was on that emotional
journey with him as he was seeing it for
the first time
that was really well done and it's
pretty much all down to his performance
it could have been really it could have
felt like just a cheesy recap of hey
remember this is what was supposed to
happen but it's like the emotional high
point of the
episode so that
that's pretty dang impressive now
there's a lot of little things that i
could bring up like i think they
had a lot of fun use of the uh sort of
technology that the tva has in terms of
like
blipping people here and there or like
uh when that agent
like smacks loki with this thing and he
basically like
reacts in slow time while she's still in
normal time
um like basically hitting him with a
time dilation rod like
that's i want to see more of that kind
of tech that was really cool or just the
idea that
this this agency has infinity stones
littering the office because here they
don't mean anything and they
are jumping into so many different
timelines they've got multiple sets of
infinity stones and it doesn't matter
who cares they're paperweights again
sort of bringing in the mundanity of
what it is that they do
and i like that but now let's spend a
little time
on what is legitimately a spoiler
so there's your warning i'm talking
about the thing that is brought up at
the very very very very
end which is that and this i kind of
called
um and i'm now going to make further
calls having now discussed this so
we see agent mobius that's owen wilson's
character you know
step in on a on a situation where some
agents have been killed when they were
trying to fix something this is
something that's been ongoing i figured
it was a version of loki right off the
bat as soon as it was mentioned oh they
were stabbed
like the other people i'm like well like
who else in the mcu uses knives and
they're not going to just introduce a
whole new character because there would
be no point in this kind of build up
that way it has to be somebody we
already know
knives are loki it's loki so
we don't really see this
other worse dangerous version of loki
now there's a couple here's what i like
about this twist right off the bat
it gives immediate context for why owen
wilson not only feels that this version
of loki that we know
could help him but also it really gives
a methodology behind
the kinds of questions he was asking him
like do you really enjoy
hurting people like trying to get to the
heart of loki to figure out
if i try and recruit you to help are you
just going to make the problem worse or
is there something
underneath the cruelty that you put
front and center and to see him
drill at that and get and crack through
it at least a little bit really good
stuff
so the fairly easily guessed
twist at this point would be that the
version of loki that we're going to be
combating that is the villain is going
to be some equivalent
of the female version of loki so a
couple of things quick reminder
loki the ancient norse mythological
figure
is genderfluid he actually is the mother
of the multi-legged horse that odin
rides
i really hope they bring that up
somewhere along the lines um
and also in the comics loki
is and has been for a period of time a
woman and it's not like the thor
situation where what happened where a
woman took up thor's mantle no loki
himself became a woman and was a woman
for a stretch of time
now i do have some concerns about this i
actually talked about those over on the
break room although
at this point my main concern over
whether or not they were even going to
go there
is probably moot now while we don't
confirm that this is female loki the
fact that we don't see the face of this
version of loki
that would be the main reason to do it
so i have a hard time believing it's
going to be anything other
than the female version of loki so
assuming i'm correct i'm
everything i say after this is on the
assumption that i'm right about that
which i'm pretty sure that i am
um like and it's it was rumored for a
while anyway that this might
be what happened so i'm gonna be really
curious to see
how they kind of explain her
existence and mainly what i mean by that
is
are they just going to chalk it up to
she escaped from some kind of alternate
timeline that wasn't supposed to exist
in the first place where loki
was always a woman
or are they actually going to present
the idea that loki
can change gender
because they could feasibly go either
way and why it
kind of matters to me is
up until this point any sort of
shifting changing of appearance that
loki's done has always been illusory
so i'm very curious as to
whether this female loki is going to be
established to
be the same i mean like not the same
because like
variance or whatever but like was
originally
at some earlier point within their own
timeline the same as the male okie we
now have
and did choose to completely
physically transform into a female
version
that's what i'm kind of hoping because
the alternatives are to either
not really address the gender fluidity
properly at all if it ends up just
coming down to
completely different timeline you know
wasn't supposed to exist in the first
place was always a woman like i said
that just dodges the issue
but the other thing is if it gets kept
as being illusory
the way we've seen loki's powers largely
work up to this point
i worry about that in the sense that it
has the potential to reinforce the idea
that gender non-conforming or gender
fluid
hi or trans people are
pretending it's an illusion and
underneath they are really
whatever they were assigned at birth
intentionally reinforcing that no but
it's it's a common undercurrent and it's
a big part of the main reason why i get
very iffy about
um cisgender people playing any kind of
trans
uh or non-binary role because
having them there at all does on some
subconscious level reinforce the idea oh
but
they're really this standard binary
gender because
the audience knows that the performer is
really that standard binary gender and
is just pretending
so it's one of the things that makes me
nervous about
introducing the gender fluid aspects of
loki at all because since tom hiddleston
is says and like look i'm not going to
suddenly say they shouldn't have cast
tom hiddleston
they're bringing this element of the
thing in way way way way later
and i i there's no way you're ever going
to convince me they were planning to go
here eventually always because if
that was the case then i would say maybe
get somebody
at least non-binary but like they didn't
this is something they're adding in
after so nothing against him and i don't
think there's anything wrong with this
casting originally
but now that he's in the role i am
nervous about how that will
be handled and depicted and it's gonna
largely come down to the fine details
and the nuances
of the situation and whether or not
it gets addressed at all or whether it's
just a gimmick
and honestly if it is just a gimmick
that is potentially
less damaging than if they try and dig
into it
and just do it badly i've said in the
past that bad representation is better
than no representation i stand by that
but i would say that just presenting a
female loki and not really touching on
it
you could put that in as like kind of
neutral leaning bad representation
because you don't do much with it you
just did it
i i would prefer that over if they try
and dig into it and screw it up
i mean there's the sliver of the
possibility they try and dig into this
and actually nail it
i i have faith in marvel on a lot of
things
i don't have a ton of faith on them on
representation
um and not because they've like
massively screwed up but like they have
been so slow to even try and touch on
this stuff
and other departments of disney have
legitimately screwed this
stuff up uh very fully so it's gonna i'm
gonna be nervous
i i'm at this point i'm expecting lady
loki
i kind of want to see lady loki but i'm
gonna be really nervous the whole way
through
every step of the way for all the fine
details of
how this is depicted how the character
is talked about
and how this is handled by
loki prime but we'll see going forward
fingers crossed is good because this is
a solid start there's a lot of good
foundation here to do some fun stuff
we'll see loki glorious purpose
what'd you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it
i have a patreon that is what pays the
bills allows me to
afford disney plus and be able to do
these reviews
at all rewards at every tier including
getting to see videos early naming the
credits and others also there are
youtube memberships if you want to go
that direction but
you don't have to like share subscribe
that helps me out as well
hit the bell why not but you don't even
have to do that
i'm not going to tell you what to do i'm
not a time keeper
you're the counsel i just run the
meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh